Alexandra Borchio-Fontimp,
sénatrice des Alpes-Maritimes,
conseillère départementale et secrétaire
générale adjointe les Républicains.
Je suis née à Antibes et j’ai démarré ma
scolarité à l’école publique de la commune
dans laquelle je suis née. Après l’obtention
de mon bac, je désirais être journaliste
donc j’ai fait des études de lettres et de
communication, durant quelques années jusqu’à
obtenir un bac +4, une maîtrise en science
de l’information et de la communication.
C’est donc grâce à ces études et à des stages
qui ont été réalisés parallèlement à mes études
que j’ai réussi à obtenir mon premier
job de journaliste. Je suis donc devenue
titulaire de la carte de
presse et j’ai été rédactrice,
présentatrice et reporter sur une
grande radio régionale de ma région.
En fait à force d’interviewer des élus,
j’ai fini par répondre à leur main tendue
et à intégrer en 2008 un Conseil municipal.
En 2008 j’ai rejoint une équipe municipale,
parce que j’avais cette volonté de vouloir
apprendre comment en coulisse, la
gestion d’une collectivité se faisait.
J’ai été piquée dès le premier jour de
ce mandat, une sorte de deuxième passion,
après mon métier de journaliste et c’est
dans cette voie que j’ai souhaité poursuivre,
travailler pour servir l’intérêt général,
travailler pour ma commune pour essayer,
tenter de l’améliorer, de proposer une
meilleure qualité de vie à mes concitoyens.
En 2020, j’ai eu l’honneur d’être élue par mes
pairs, notamment par une grande majorité d’élus
de mon département des Alpes-Maritimes, Sénatrice
et donc de siéger au palais du Luxembourg.
Je suis honorée d’avoir été, d’abord reconnue
par mes pairs, puisqu’arriver à siéger ici,
je pense et j’espère en tout cas, c’est
qu’ils ont placé beaucoup de confiance
et de reconnaissance en mon engagement et en
mon travail à leurs côtés. Donc je prends ce
mandat très au sérieux, en restant vraiment
les pieds sur terre dans mon territoire.
J’ai toujours œuvré dans l’intérêt collectif
comme beaucoup de mes collègues. Je pense
que c’est essentiel de garder ce qui
fait mes qualités ou ma personnalité,
mon caractère. C’est-à-dire la proximité,
rester au contact de la population pour
essayer humblement de porter leur voix. Souvent
le Sénat renvoie une image un peu conservatrice,
ancienne, c’est vrai que la moyenne d’âge est
un peu plus élevée que l’âge que je peux avoir.
Mais, je trouve que ce renouvellement
dans les Chambres, cette féminisation,
ce rajeunissement apportent beaucoup, on a un
regard différent, on offre un regard nouveau,
connecté à la réalité. Et je
pense que cet équilibre et cette
complémentarité sont nécessaires aujourd’hui au
sein de notre famille politique. Être représenté,
que la droite soit représentée par tout un
éventail de personnalités et de générations.
J’ai plusieurs causes qui me tiennent à cœur.
Parallèlement à mes activités professionnelles
et à mes mandats, je suis marraine d’une
association pour enfants malades. J’ai vraiment,
en tant que bénévole, l’envie d’abord d’améliorer
le quotidien des enfants et de leur famille.
Il y a une autre cause que je
défends aussi officiellement.
Je siège à la délégation des droits des
femmes, je suis membre du Haut Conseil à
l’Egalité entre les hommes et les femmes.  Mes délégations
dans le département des Alpes-Maritimes donc là
aussi, je veux, humblement être leur porte-parole,
mieux protéger encore les femmes, que ce soit
des victimes de violences mais tout simplement,
les femmes qui notamment, depuis la crise
sanitaire sont tombées dans la précarité.
Donc voilà, ce sont deux combats, je suis
très fière de pouvoir porter leurs voix.
Je m’inspire de beaucoup de personnalités.
D’abord les plus proches à commencer par
Jean Léonetti. C’est le maire qui m’a tendu la
main et qui m’a accompagnée durant mes mandats
et qui m’accompagne encore aujourd’hui. Le
maire chez qui je puise beaucoup de choses. Ou
d’une génération avant, Simone Veil notamment,
dont je salue le combat, l’abnégation. Voilà,
cette détermination, qui pour moi est essentielle
dans l’engagement. Ce sont aussi des hommes et des
femmes politiques, comme Christian Jacob, qui
me donnent envie de poursuivre mon engagement
et de travailler à ses côtés. C’est un homme
de valeurs, de convictions auquel j’adhère
depuis de nombreuses années, et que je suis
depuis mon plus jeune âge dans son parcours.
Alors, c’est vrai que je fais beaucoup de
politique et je n’ai pas vraiment de loisirs
en particulier si ce n’est que d’essayer
de profiter un maximum de ma famille. J’ai
deux enfants de dix et douze ans. Ce sont des
moments de joie et de bonheur avec eux donc,
dès que j’ai un moment, le temps est pour eux.
Et puis mes moments aussi libres, je les passe
en tant que bénévole dans des associations
caritatives, notamment dans une association
qui œuvre pour les enfants malades, qui
s’appelle l’association « Adrien » mais aussi,
à la Croix-Rouge quand elle manque de bénévoles,
de temps en temps, j’enfile un gilet, et je vais
faire des maraudes la nuit pour apporter un peu de
réconfort et de chaleur aux sans domiciles fixes.
Voilà, ce sont des missions que je fais un
peu dans l’anonymat mais qui me font du bien,
et c’est une façon pour moi, même si ce
ne sont pas de missions joyeuses qui me
régénèrent et elles me permettent
aussi de me confronter, voilà,
pas qu’aux dorures du palais du
Luxembourg et qui rappelle combien
la vie peut être fragile et combien la
précarité touche de personnes en France.
Alors on y mange bien dans les Alpes-Maritimes
puisque c’est une gastronomie méditerranéenne
avec beaucoup d’influences italiennes. On a
beaucoup de spécialités de chez nous. Alors il
y a le pain bagnat, la pissaladière, la socca,
ce sont des spécialités de chez nous, qui sont
bien appréciées par les locaux, mais pas que !
On a la chance, sur toutes nos villes côtières,
je pense, notamment chez moi à Antibes d'avoir
des pêcheurs qui pêchent leurs poissons la nuit,
qui les vendent sur les étals à partir de
six heures du matin, et, on peut les déguster
fraîchement pêchés ça c'est vraiment une chance !
Un autre métier que j'ai toujours voulu faire,
c'était pompier. En fait, je crois que
j'aime bien rendre service et donner de
ma personne pour aider les autres et donc
c'est une fonction qui me plaît beaucoup,
peut-être un jour pouvoir endosser le costume.
A la dernière cérémonie de la Sainte-Barbe,
c'est la Sainte patronne des pompiers, la caserne
d'Antibes et son Capitaine, m’ont offert un casque
parce qu'ils savent combien je suis derrière
l'ensemble de nos sapeurs-pompiers de France
qu'ils soient professionnels ou volontaires. Ça
m'a beaucoup touchée, c'est d’ailleurs le premier
objet que j'ai mis dans mon bureau parlementaire
à Antibes. Je viens de m'installer y a quelques
jours et je me dis que peut-être un jour,
j'aurais moi aussi mon propre casque de pompier.